[Music]
if i could
quit being an actor and be a full-time
poet and be successful at it i would do
it
but i don't think there's any money in
poetry
and also
i'm a little intimidated by it but i
love what i think probably my favorite
thing to do artistically is to write a
poem really yeah do you write any
recently i know a lot of people loved uh
billy's debonair hair poem yeah that's
quite good
that went viral yeah
today i don't have debonair hair i have
well i have what i call high hair
so see how my hair's basically straight
up and down yeah there's no wave to it
at all
it's straight up and down but it's also
got forward motion thank you it's a
little
kind of a little max headroomy and it
was way worse until i looked in the
rearview mirror of my car and i thought
that's not cool that's like a flat top
so then i pushed it down and kind of
messed it about
i love it i actually really like it oh
thanks bills anyway we're here we kind
of started the podcast very
casually this week because uh
john was telling us about poetry but
honestly that is true you know if i
could
choose a medium an artistic medium in
which it could pay my bills and i could
satiate myself financially
i'd be a poet i said i said i think it's
a it's a noble pursuit and you can die
penniless in spain
true there's something so romantic about
a poet yeah and
i've always loved vigo's poetry and the
i think probably probably vigo's
one of the more
influential
poets for me and my favorite thing about
vigo and i think the thing that i took
from
consistently swapping poems with vigo
over the years
it's a brilliant note
when i was when we were doing rings when
i was like 23 vigo said
try and take as many words out the poem
as possible yeah you want to simmer it
down i'm sure you'll like this when
you're songwriting
you want to simmer it down you don't
want you don't need the end you don't
need the so you don't need the maybe try
and get the feeling that you're trying
to achieve
with the barest minimum words possible
yeah and that's what i subscribe to i
have written
poems that might go over two pages but
it's on it's uncommon
it tends to be
a couple of verses
and my favorite thing that i've done for
the past like two or three years is
because i don't tend to be that
disciplined with poetry but in the last
couple of years what i've done is
written a verse wrote the word love
underneath it written another verse and
wrote the word love twice underneath it
and kind of explored this idea of
love in a whole bunch of different ways
it started out when my when my nephew
was born
so i wrote a poem about my nephew little
baby boy i was like oh so much love
wrote about that and then i thought oh
what about
how my brother thinks about his son what
about how my mom thinks about her
grandson that's all different so looking
at love from different angles and
slightly
kind of
fitting myself into a discipline of
a poem instead of write whatever you
want you know i think that's very good
though i think um you know like all art
forms
we're trying to make sense of things
in a sort of
not a poetic way but just trying to
distill things in
whether it's a painting a poem music
whatever it is
which takes us back to time
time
it's filling
time before we die yeah i just started
reading uh
brian green's new book right he's a
quantum physicist sort of yeah physicist
mathematician and he's talking about
time and why do we create is it somehow
to full time to become
um
you know to to to go past or sell by
date
maybe
i don't know i think i told you that my
favorite feeling on the planet right now
this is a few podcasts ago
is doing something yes and then knowing
what i'm going to do just after that
feeling so i'm gardening yeah i think
i'm coming towards the end of my
gardening and then i have this thought
of okay once you're done with that maybe
make some lunch and that contented
feeling of i'm in an activity i'm
transitioning to another one and i know
what it is it's a beautiful feeling
is that
in some way
kind of that buddhist thing of just
living in the moment it might be the
it's kind of like in the moment it's
just slightly longer than it was yeah it
might be the but i think i think that
probably is you're just excited about
the moment just to go back very briefly
to yeah poetry and songwriting and all
that kind of stuff because my brother
writes uh songs
and he does it in his own unique fashion
but for you
do you have a melody and you put the
lyrics to it or do you think of kind of
a poem and then try and put a melody to
it no normally it's melody first and
then i fit the words to that and i try
to do that in
in whatever sort of interesting or
poetic way that i can so you might be
walking around your house doing whatever
blah blah and then
suddenly you have a little kind of
jingly thing in your head and you spend
a bit of time thinking is that
a beatles song is that a led zeppelin
song and if it's not then you start to
kind of flesh it out but normally i'm
sitting with an instrument normally
guitar and when i do that if i'm just
going round the house then it'll be
normally just comedy songs songs about
the dog or why the fridge light doesn't
work or things like that
but if it's an actual song then i'm
normally on an instrument and then
actually thinking about chords and as
you see
distilling it you know at
probably the last few years i got very
into kind of playing with tempos and and
weird chord structures but that's all
coming back to
you know just play three chords and just
just uh think of a good melody you know
and a massive mistake that i made in my
younger years and i i
endeavor to not do it nowadays because
the amount of times i've done it and i
thought no this time it'll be different
and it's never different
is if you've got an idea or a thought or
whatever a melody and and it's night
time and you go to sleep and you think
i'll remember that in the morning you
will not remember it in the morning will
you well a lot of people say that's why
leonard and mccartney were so brilliant
is because they had each other in the
room and they wouldn't leave the room
till the song was done brilliant whereas
if it was just mccartney he might have
got a verse and went
i'll finish this after lunch yeah and
you wouldn't finish it
and uh i think it's a big thing in our
isn't it actually take the time to do it
that's that for me anyway i don't know
about you that's the most difficult
thing for me yeah to finish to have the
start of an idea and get through and
then say i'm actually going to sit here
for two hours and finish it yeah
it's difficult that's when studios i
think come into their own or office
space when you come out of the house and
you're in in a place where you know
that's what you're doing for that time
right the structure yeah yeah i've had
it because there's something magical in
your brain going on as you're falling
asleep or as you're just waking up in
the morning
and i have had
fully constructed fully realized poems
as i'm falling asleep at night ah this
oh that's great great cool
so just remember the start of it and
then the rest of it will flow in the
morning and wake up in the morning
it's gone yeah so now i just have my
voice recorder on my phone and i just
speak in and sometimes it's a magical
idea
and sometimes i'll wake up in the
morning listen to it and be like that's
total nonsense but you will always
regret if you don't try and get some of
it down right
yeah absolutely
i did dream about zombies last night
really yeah were you good did you
survive uh
yeah but it wasn't easy i've watched a
few zombie movies lately i don't know if
that's what's got to do with it possibly
but you were there oh good my family
were there and i had to think of ways of
saving us thanks and when i was younger
we lived in a masonette do you know what
masonette is tiny little house no it's
like a lot of like houses up stairs and
downstairs on top of each other like
three levels and they're sort of like a
box
so
when you're in the bedrooms upstairs
if there was a fire downstairs does
kinda know where to get out and i think
my dad must have thought of this
and one day he walked in with a rope
like a lot like a mountain climber's
rope i was i was that far
and he said well if there's a fire i'll
lure you guys out the window brilliant
and i got a rope for all of us last
night oh great when i locked all the
doors with the zombies outside
to lure us down nice thanks no worries
have you
died in dreams before i don't think so
i've died a few times now people always
say you can't die in dreams i've died at
least at least three or four times that
i can remember plane crashes quite often
oh really so i'll die
bernie heart bro body coming apart and
then i'll be like oh but definitely dead
not just harmed no no dead like as like
a spirit like an entity now walking
around and someone asked me a while ago
do i have a reoccurring dream and i did
not think that i did and i've now come
to realize that i do have a reoccurring
dream because it's happened quite a bit
i just keep forgetting about it and you
you were in it recently
i'm at an airport yeah desperately
trying to get to a flight
and there's some sort of distraction
that takes
me and you in the last yeah away from
the gate so the last time you and i were
in a lounge oprah winfrey was there
she was chatting to us we're like yeah
yeah great oprah that's fantastic we
gotta get to this flight
and she's delaying us delaying his lens
and then as we leave someone's trying to
sell us flowers and we head in the wrong
direction and i'm panicking because we
can't make the flight and i read
that being late
to get to a fly or struggling to get to
an airplane and all this kind of stuff
is that you're moving into a new
part of your life a new transitional
part of your life and you have some
insecurity about what you leave behind
now that does that mean you're leaving
me yeah i'm going that's a [ __ ] that
makes sense because we're always
everything's always changing oh
everything's changing can i just make my
last point on zombies that i just
thought please please
zombie updates on me update one i wrote
a script right it's brilliant of course
it is it's comedy
it's got music in it zombie it's no
so
and with pete jackson a few years ago
yeah i give him the script have you read
that pete yeah thinking to myself he'll
probably give me five or ten million
dollars
right i'll get very least green light
you'll green later billy i'll produce it
i can't direct it a bit busy i'll
produce it with you i gave him it and he
said to me is there zombies in it
i said no and i knew at that moment he
will never read that script
yeah that's honestly what he said
it's just a romantic comedy with some
music
there's a script pete is there zombies
in it no you should have said
there will be about six o'clock okay
you're giving me back
and we'll just feather it
just can't cut my zombies in there he's
best makes a zombie now pete but um
isn't that a brilliant first question
about the script brilliant he's just
pete's everything's on fast forward with
pete in terms of what he's doing with
his life so i love the fact that he's
like well that's that's where my hands
are he he had
he used to talk to us on rings didn't he
had an idea for a
zombie meets war movie
remember oh yeah i do first world war
was the first world war so the weapons
are not quite as yeah i do remember long
distance and in the trenches there's
kind of a we shouldn't say this because
someone's going to go write it now but
it's probable
but in the trenches there's like that
i love this word a pestilence
pestilence and boils and warts and stuff
and that creates like a
zombie thing so not only are you
fighting
the enemy
but also your
your co-workers well let's call them
that soldier pals what would you call
them you you
your army mates well
those guys some of them are breaking out
with
zombie diseases
billy and dom eat the world
billy what
we're actually going to slightly change
the order of things tell me because
we're going to eat the world because the
food that we're going to eat does better
when it's hot and it's currently cooling
down as we speak so we're going to eat
the world now billy and dom eat the
world start the show and then we'll
we'll tarantino it will go backwards
forwards i don't mind that dorm cause
then it's sort of like my second
breakfast oh lovely stuff here comes
john here comes john and all eyes are on
him isn't he a great looking guy
so we have
fries of sort french fries freedom fries
surely this isn't what we're testing
today john we've all tried fries before
we are testing hang on oh there's a
mouse here i'm going to scroll down to
where this thing is right we are testing
ladies and gentlemen
i think we're testing fry's sauce
[Music]
[Applause]
now this was brought to us by
laura may
emma l brittany l chad shipley
smc utah
courtney w from utah braden cayesville
from ut lots of people from utah i'm
guessing this is something that is quite
popular in utah billy tell them
we are eating
fry sauce which was created in the late
1940s by don carlos edwards founder of
the utah bay's fast food chain arctic
circle originally called pink sauce the
recipe includes ketchup meal garlic and
a mix of other spices to create an
instant hit condiment that was perfect
for french fries now i get the feeling
i've not even tried it yet but i did uh
give it a little bit of a sniff there i
get the feeling this is one of those
sources
like you had said that's a combination
of all the things that you kind of want
to put on
chips or fries ketchup mayo maybe a
little spice little vinegar it's
everything all in one
hey guys i'm doing a little bit of
traveling right now but i do not leave
the country without a few cartons of
magic
spoon cereal it's my favorite thing it's
basically a healthy cereal let me give
you a few stats here guys to keep you
interested zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving that
makes it a super healthy cereal not only
that it's only 140 calories a serving
and it's keto friendly it's gluten free
it's grain free it's soy free and it's
low carb you can build your own box or
get a variety pack with available
flavors cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter my favorite
blueberry and cinnamon and there's a few
more
special flavors that they bring out
every so often in the year i just got a
maple waffle flavor which goes really
well with oatmeal so guys go to
magicspoon.com to get your delicious
cereal and try it today and be sure to
use our promo code onion at checkout to
save five dollars off your order magic
spoon is so confident in their product
that it's backed with a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at
magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode
hey guys
summer's here and there's never been a
better time to try a shirt from
untucking
i just packed a case one of the first
things that i put in that case are my
shirts from untuck it because after a
long flight you pull them out they're
crease free they look fantastic and you
can wear them on your first night out
they have performance shirts that wick
sweat which is fantastic they also have
short sleeve shirts and polo shirts that
are made to beat the heat
antucket shirts are perfect as we
transition back to the things that we've
been missing like dinners with friends
reuniting with families going off
working somewhere and of course going on
holiday they have sizes that fit me
hobbit sized all the way up to triple xl
so there's a style and a size for
everyone out there use the code onion
for 20 off your first purchase at
untuckit.com
that's onion for 20
of your first purchase at untuckit.com
if i was making a a burger
burger a sort of um you know a veggie
burger or a real burger dude ma
i would mix
mayo and ketchup and put it on the bun
what would you do well just to pick you
up on that point didn't your wonderful
wife a few weeks ago whilst you were
making us veggie burgers on the bbq
didn't she fashion up a little ketchup
mayo something else sauce maybe i've got
the idea from her so she might be making
she might be making utah fry sauce
without us knowing it i like that stuff
oh are you going already i like that
stuff but i have to tell you because i
bought a massive jar of it
if i'm putting stuff on a burger now
tell me
ketchup and that jardin here you put the
jazz into chardonnay on a burger so it's
all oily and chilis and
i would love to look back at our
jardinera episode and see what we gave
it for usefulness because that stuff is
useful it's one of my favorite moments
in the podcast up to now and i watch it
every so often if i want to have a laugh
is your reaction when you first do you
oh dumb oh
you're like overcome with how tasty it
is it is so good well should we give
this a go right ready uh all right i'm
gonna give it a little sniff it's always
good to you know start
giving it a little yeah it's definitely
got a meal ketchup sort of sniff to it
now
have you been to in-n-out burger before
i have done
they do a fantastic uh
burger there and i get the feeling that
their kind of secret sauce that they use
is similar to this no it's fair now it's
kyle
you know if you get asked for a veggie
burger and then a note
you know what you get
if you never ask for a veggie burger and
then a note do you get a slap in the
face no
you get the bun
the lettuce and tomato
that's it
that's a statement isn't it no i mean
that's a statement and they have
supposedly
this is a piece about in and out burger
but supposedly in and out burger they
have a lot of secret things like you
know
animal style means that they grill
onions and all that kind of stuff now
let's read it a little bit more stuff
i'll tell you what that is good good
for those who haven't encountered uh
what christensen calls the ultimate
dipping sauce who's christianson
fry sauce
is and it's most simple an equal mix of
ketchup and mayonnaise but we don't know
who christensen is was it invented by a
man called christensen
no john carlos edwards of course well
who the heck is christiansen i love
john's randomness of his as his facts
what christiansen calls the ultimate
dipping sauce hello christensen
also in japanese steakhouses this is
sometimes called yum yum sauce
which makes sense because it's it's
pretty yummy um
casey christiansen is the chief
operating officer for arctic circle
restaurants of course
of course of course yes we should have
known that bills no now some people
mistake fry sauce for thousand island
it's not the same it's not the same but
i can see where that comes from them
which is also built on a mayonnaise base
but their tangy flavor is brought by
tabasco
oh here's a word i've never been able to
say
worcestershire is that right i think
you've done it i think that would be
the longer version of the word
worcestershire sauce sometimes people
showing it and just say worcester sauce
don't they worcester yeah worcestershire
it's one of those words where i stop
before i see it because i know i'll
probably get it wrong yeah because you
struggle saying the recent um
ufc champion's name don't you dustin
that's another one where i stopped and
now you've told me how to say it so i'm
good dustin
pourier oh there you go billy used to
say dustin
[Music]
there you go any addition to make to to
making leaving its mark on the american
west
fry sauce
lives a peculiar double life as salsa
gulf in argentina what does that mean
after being invented no less by a nobel
prize winner really well abrogado the
condiment made a quick sweep through
central america eastern europe and the
balkan countries and select few
countries in the middle east before the
comparable thousand island dressing
popped up in a new orleans cookbook and
probably stole its thunder in the 1900s
um
well fantastic news would you want to
hear a legend behind it don't go on tell
us a legend oh and get this guy's name
legend has it
that argentine biochemist and physician
louis federico le lua nice who received
the prize in chemistry in 1970 after
discovering the metabolic powers of
sugar nuclear thai diets
he stumbled upon his version of the fry
sauce while on vacation in eastern
argentina argentina
according to victor de cruz los sabres
de la patria
leloa
was with friends and colleagues in mar
del plata a coastal vacation spot near
buenos aires when he decided he didn't
want to eat shellfish with the standard
mayonnaise
his waiter was happy to bring him a slew
of singular ingredients from the kitchen
vinegar lemon mustard sugar and
ketchup
the chemist who was i suppose used to
mixing things simply couldn't resist and
it wasn't long before
salsa golf named after the golf reports
their resorts restaurant where they
enjoyed the meal was created fantastic a
chemist did it chemistry we've got all
other people around the world kind of
inventing it at the same time although
that's not outside the realms of
possibilities because it is basically
ketchup with mayonnaise right
it's not it's not that difficult to make
but it is it's very yummy
it would be nice if these chips stroke
thrice thighs
but fries so why so many people from
utah
i think it must be a staple in utah
right but um is that um
go back to this the top there done i'd
love to you know where it all started
yeah with the um
um that uh arctic what's it called
circle ah they're utah based there yeah
utah based so it's very very popular
there nice to support you you want to
use some idea of what senate dot go um
right
the rating is very small mm-hmm you
ready what
what do you think's the first the first
ingredient first ingredient
sugar no ketchup no mayonnaise no eggs
nope flour no
lasers no i've lost it now it's a type
of oil and it begins with s
something oil s
oil then all i was going to say canola
soy oil soybean oil soybean oil and then
ketchup ketchup and then mayonnaise then
vinegar sugar and salt high fructose oh
that's a shame yeah and then the rest is
underneath the sticker so i can't tell
you what the rest is
but there's a lot of you know gazan and
oh my god
spices turmeric calcium
something's added anyway delicious
delicious delicious i like it it's tasty
anything else here that's interesting
it's basically they're saying that it's
there's a lot of different versions of
it all
excuse me all around the world which
makes sense nice on chips or fries now
anything else that you think it would be
excellent on i think it would be good on
a burger yeah i think as a burger sauce
it'd be absolutely perfect
um and what when they first started
making it they said people loved it so
much that they started taking it home to
put on their own burgers and hot dogs
and chicken sandwiches and everything
else it needed flavor
so that's why they have named it the
anything sauce ah yes
fits with anything now you know that
kind of
sometimes
pastory dish that people do which is
kind of like you know the bow tie pasta
which i think is fusilli right yeah i
think it's foreseeable yeah you're
correct is it for zealand i think it's
pussily
i think for zelie's the swirls well you
said it
it's foulfully bow tie butterfly pasta
how will we ever remember it make a way
that we will remember hold on till we
get john to check it first is it falfi
is bow tie butterfly pasta john
which which pasta shape what is the name
of the pasta shape that is in fact a bow
tie or a butterfly a birthday
i did misspoke misspeak and say fuzzily
but i think that's the swirls you're
right farfilay
um falfaleh
if i was to say
falflay
you'd know it was a bow tie never eat a
foul shrimp eat foul a little no no no
no it's gonna be a bow tie or a
butterfly tie
if it's a bow tie or a butterfly you
have to say fully
yeah there you go so that cause you'd
like this
fal filet pasta right but maybe a few
shrimps maybe you've got
something else that goes in there
and you stir in
a little bit of
fry sauce so it's got a little thousand
dollars it's a little thousand island
but not as dense as a thousand islands
not as thick should we give it some
scores what's the scores in the doors
on the doors well we're starting with
flavor hang on i'm just gonna use my
finger now right to get a real flavor
explosion
flavor
i mean it's flavorful i like that sweet
and a little a little is it peacock is
that it's got a little
like a tiny little kick up the ass let's
get to giving you a very short kick in
the bowl yeah
i'm gonna give it for flavor because
it's it's you know it's
it's tasty
7.6 6.8
nice flavor but not for you it's sorry
it's a bit subtle it doesn't move the
needle in fact i should have been higher
and but it's just like it tastes like
other things
while we often hear the average adult
should get seven to nine hours of sleep
at night that's not always possible more
and more people are forced to make
lifestyle changes to get more deep sleep
the good news is that research has shown
that quality matters just as much as
quantity but what exactly is deep sleep
and how do we achieve this
the first half of the night is your deep
sleep window that's when things start to
drop your heart rate your breathing your
blood pressure your muscle activity and
also your body temperature
since that temperature drop is such a
crucial aspect of the deep sleep stage
finding ways to activate that sleep
switch can help increase your levels of
deep sleep and that is where chilly
sleep comes in
chilly sleep make customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that help you
improve
your entire well-being
chili sleep makes the ula and cube sleep
systems hydro powered temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
your ideal sleep temperature
head over to chilisleep.com
onion to learn more and save 20
off the purchase of any new sleep system
this offer is available exclusively for
the friendship onion listeners and only
for a limited time
that's chile c h i l i sleep dot com
slash onion to take advantage of our
exclusive discount and wake up
refreshed every day
hey guys feels like things are reverting
back to normal lots of people getting
back to their jobs and maybe you're
planning a holiday or maybe you're
planning dinner with friends or you're
going to a concert or maybe you're just
looking forward to standing in line at
the post office for hours no
some things about normal life should
never revert back to those times but
with stamps.com you can skip trips to
the post office and save on postage
mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer send letters
ship packages and pay less a lot less
with discounted rates from usps and ups
stamps.com saves businesses thousands of
hours and tons of money every year
they offer deals you can't get anywhere
else like up to 40
off usps and up to 66
of ups shipping rates
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com
instead there's no risk and with our
promo code onion you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in
onion that's stamps.com promo code onion
stamps.com
never go to the post office again
aesthetics
i wouldn't say it's the most attractive
color would you like it to be lighter or
darker
i think i'd like it to be
darker maybe a little bit more ketchup
in there so it's a slightly reddish
thing you know that stuff
you know because you at one point had a
baby who is now a young man
you know that stuff that babies puke up
when they're very small
posit is that right well i don't know
what that's called it's like the breasts
it looks a little bit like positive or
maybe the stuff that they leave in a
nappy stroke diaper when they're very
young oh yeah which is not poop is it
it's like a
strange kind of mustardy thing it must
still be purple but poop only created
from breast milk so it has a strange
consistency so a sauce that looks like
baby shite okay so in terms of its
aesthetic and the bottle yeah
i'm giving it a three
i hear you and now that you've said that
it's kind of put me off at lopes sorry
but there's something about it that kind
of cries americana to me i could see
myself in a diner and and and you know
the writing and the red
and then the color of the sauce i'm
going to give it a 6.5 nice yeah i could
see you in a diner eating that with it
with a plate of very warm french fries
say hey sweetheart yeah bring me a pair
of french fries and uh extra serving of
fry sauce and now can i get a shake with
that okay give me a vanilla shake and
then she comes over and she says how
long are you staying in town you say
listen sweetheart you walk away
hey you are you don't want to mess with
me
you and i we're star cross lovers you go
west i go east we're just ship smashing
and they're not the guy for you
sweetheart and then she leaves the
number on the website
cindy call me whenever and you're like i
can't do it sweetheart i'm out of here
i'm gonna break your heart i broke a
thousand dame's hearts across a thousand
planets and you're not the person for me
just walk away and she throws her she
throws an apron down god damn you sonny
i quit getting out of here it's over
and you're like oh all the dimes in all
the world and your friend who's there
having dinner with you says how do you
do that you say that's just something i
do it's what i do the ladies they love
me pass me the freight shots yeah see
that that could have happened in fact
that probably did happen in a parallel
universe yeah of course it does cindy
lovely cindy now your wife is a
beautiful woman
but cindy she's got those you know those
tight little american curls really tight
oh you're asking for trouble dog oh yeah
yeah she's a naughty woman anyway we'll
leave cindy for another day aesthetics
it's not done very well and finally i
think this is where the high scores come
in usefulness well no
obviously you can dip fries in it
stick it on your burger stick it on your
burger stick it on your your chicken
sandwich now i wouldn't do this but
would people dip a pizza yes yes
yes they would
especially if you're from utah and by
the way there's a map of america i'm
holding up my hand for people who are
just listening
where is utah i think you've told me
this before
my wrist is california my middle finger
is new york right
where is utah is it on the on the callus
of your middle finger here yeah
i have absolutely no idea good well
thanks for the reference as uh i thought
you were going to tell us i don't know
idea is elijah from utah he's from cedar
rapids which is iowa
which supposedly has some of the biggest
skies in the world which is always
confusing to me i feel like skies are
the same size yeah i always think that
but supposedly in iowa you come outside
your front door and you go [ __ ] you now
look at the size of that one but the sky
goes from horizon to horizon doesn't it
no matter where you are so they say how
can it be bigger i think is it very flat
a flat sky not that land is flat so you
can see
longer
although elijah's
basically blind isn't it he can't see
nothing can't see a thing anyway
usefulness
the other thing i was gonna say hot dog
yeah give me a hot dog earl here you go
here's a hot dog buddy hey give me some
of that [ __ ] fry sauce on top of it
some onions as well don't forget the
bako what's with the f-bombs i don't
know i'm hungry
yeah
and you did see a pasta
with a shrimp on it i thought that would
really get you going if you had to say
fusilli
it would either be a
healthfully thinking of fazili
if you had to say it's either a bow tie
or a
i think you say
i have fallen foul
of not wearing a bow tie fal filet do
you know what i mean that's a good way
to remember no no come on let's sign
that do you have a favorite shape of
pasta uh i just like a penny
not the shape of a penny penne pine like
a tube because that way if i want a lot
of sauce i'll stuff it in the tube
like using my fork
not like you know stuffing it
or if i don't want a lot on i'll just
touch it on the top of the the penny
then
i like fall filet the bow tie pasta
and physique fancy isn't it it is fancy
and a bit precious and the other one
which you don't find too often but i
really enjoy it when you get it is
the one that kind of looks like a
miniature uh
wheel like a wagon have you seen that i
have no idea what that one's called no
wagon or sweet loss
let's guess anyway usefulness i'm giving
it a
9.5 for usefulness very good.dom i'll go
slightly under there because i think
everything's going to taste like fry
sauce when you stick it on yeah but
other than that a 9.2 absolutely
fantastic thank you everyone who sent
that in thank you the state of utah and
why don't we jump straight into
voicemails from lovely listeners peoples
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snails
hi my name is nigel i'm from fort worth
texas i'm just wondering
if you could have anybody narrate your
life
in the same sense as stranger than
fiction where willfurro's life is being
narrated by emma thompson
who would you pick and why
love the show listen to it all the time
take care
that that's a good question great answer
nigel no not an answer question question
yeah i just watched a bit of that film
it was on tv the other day it's really
smart stranger than pitching yeah
there's will ferrell in it yeah have you
never seen it no oh you must watch it
love him he's he can hear the narrator
of his life
in his head and it turns out sema
thompson and she's writing a novel
with him in it
and anything she writes happens to him
and he hears it and it's really
interesting oh that's cool check it out
so who would you have in your head
narrating your story ah dom goes into
the supermarket to pick up some blah
blah blah excuse me
well i i think is she called mindy mindy
carling
yes yes
um she has quite a a sweet kind of
playful right joyful voice uh-huh i
quite like her to juxtapose
i've got fry sauce in the back of my
throat don't worry about that juxtapose
maybe you know some of the more
earnest serious things that you go
through whilst also colouring the
majority of my life's journey with a
little sprinkle of uh
silliness and uh whimsy well i think
that's lovely dog yeah i've just thought
that lin mindy carling i think she's
cool what about you
um olivia
oh yeah larry
no it's john gilligan
i think i'd just love to hear john
johnny in my head dear dear johnny yes
yeah he was the guy in arthur was he was
he arthas yes he was the spoiled little
bastard
[Laughter]
i'll have him why not junkie that's
lovely so john gill good thank you nigel
thank you nigel all the way from texas
to your fry sauce
hi dom and billy this is gloria and i'm
so happy you started a podcast because
anytime the two of you get together it's
just a barrel of laughs
my question for you is
what is a song
that
you guys go to whenever you need to pick
me up
thanks
thanks gloria
great memorization gli all right gloria
yellow orion glory um
i know mine because i have mine in heavy
rotation do you
go
for once in my life by the wonderful
stephen wonder
wonderful yeah little stevie wonder used
to be called and then he grew and then
he grew and then he grew uh that's an
amazing song it's just like
come on that's one chance let's go after
it enjoy it
what about you well here's i'll tell you
something that happened yesterday i was
driving with my wife
and were listening some music and i just
got an idea dom
i thought to myself you know what i'll
put on
the soundtrack of the movie
greece
and we had a wonderful hour's drive
my wife i didn't know knows every word
of every song in greece well she's very
much a musical theater woman but she
sang all the parts didn't let me sing
any even in the
duets hopelessly devoted to you olivia
newton john that is a heartbreakingly
brilliant performance
and i mean summer loving fantastic
grease lightning are you kidding me
brilliant i like the song the rizzo song
which doesn't really tend to feature
that highly in other people's
likings of the greece soundtrack which
one the the beauty skill the beauty
school that's the frenchy one ah the
rizzo one is about you know i can't
remember how it goes but she's basically
saying no one really
has any faith in me no one thinks i'm
gonna do anything but i am gonna do
something but then she doesn't do that
she doesn't she just gets pregnant oh
well anyway let's move on
thank you gloria
dominic yes would you like to do the
first question it's from asher and wales
okay hello asha great name there he said
i know that you guys love music i want
to ask you an opinion on cds tapes or
vinyl do you prefer physical or digital
should we all go digital and leave
physical albums behind i myself i'm in
the physical copies camp i started up a
cd collection i even bought a vinyl last
year
if you have them what are some of your
favorite albums or album covers what's a
lot of questions here asha yeah which
all kind of dilutes into the um
what do you think about you know
uh cds tapes vinyl
and streaming them here i'll i'll keep
going please i'm talking ah sure here's
my thinking here
i think it's brilliant
that you can stream virtually any song
like i said i was in the car yesterday
and i just said i'll listen to the album
of greece yeah and bang there it goes
it's in the car it's in my wife's ears
and we're both singing along
now you couldn't have done that with
when it was cds and certainly not with
vinyl no and
i totally get the vinyl thing
i love like
when i think about it when adam ant left
adam in the ants
and he brought out his first solo album
friend or foe i think it was called i
went on the 51 bus into town i was so
excited and i got the album and i read
it all of it all the way home
and then i put it on the record player
and that memory is still exciting yes
but
am i ready to start buying new vinyl
like i've got all my old vinyl from the
80s 90s
but i don't have a record player just
now right and i know if i bought a
record player then i'd be buying vinyl
again
do i want to go down that road i don't
know i don't know
because i can get any music not all
music but any music almost almost any
music streaming into my ears yeah
whenever a fancy and as long as you get
a high quality make sure you get a high
quality gosh yeah high definition
and most of these companies will now do
that amazon apple and i mean i don't
know if i don't know
but i don't want to advertise but
maybe i'll go the albums again but i
don't want to have to
i don't need more physical things in my
life as well no no
less pressure less stuff stuff no i need
to go buy more albums uh but i do get
how wonderful albums are dominic william
give me your thoughts
that amazing
uh line in fight club in the book and
also features in the
in the film the things you own end up
owning you which i think is such a
simple thing but it is true you're like
well
i'd love to go on holiday or i'd love to
move or i'd love to do this but i've got
that i've got and like did we really
ever have any of those things it's all
passing through isn't it and then it's
something to worry about what if
somebody comes and steals all my albums
right and my record player what if
somebody comes into my house and steals
my record zombies come in and steal my
record player you should have written
that and presented that to pete jackson
you would have been a bazillionaire by
now everybody would have gone to see
that movie i totally would a zombie
stole my record player right brilliant
well
i think tapes are gone right i mean he
mentioned tapes tapes come on tapes it's
not
you know it's not gonna happen anymore i
used to be the it's not is it no one's
gonna be like oh let me get that on tape
hold on
if i said to you back in the day
dom
would you make me a mixtape
no come on how excited would you have
been mixtape is fantastic and i know we
went into mixed cds it doesn't have the
same level of romanticism right i was
also the guy
in my house that was very good at
like fixing a slightly unspooled tape
cassette you know my brother would come
in and go this is ruined i'd be like
ruined go get me a pencil hang on a
second and you'd straighten it usb hb
and you all you'd have to do is you'd
have to slowly twist it back in without
it having any of the twists gone back
into the tape
so as it goes in you make sure that it
unspools and i don't know if you i think
you do know this about me one of my
favorite things ever to do in my life is
to untangle stuff
i it's not weird
i used to love back when playstations
were connected to the to the machine and
you had four of them
all four of the controllers oh hello all
four of the controllers used to tangle
up and i used to go over to friends
houses and they'd say let's play fifa
and i'd say can i untangle all your
controllers first and they'd be like
yeah we don't want to do that and i'd be
like i really want to do that i love it
and then would you just go home well i
do find it very soothing i don't know
it's i don't know what that's about but
anyway tapes i think tapes is not part
of the thing i do have a record player
in my house i have one and i still have
a record collection some of which i've
commandeered from my parents because
they don't listen to records anymore and
it is brilliant to like listen to an old
you know
pull like simon and garfunkel vinyl from
the mid-60s you know i mean that that is
amazing i do love what spotify has done
or any of those kind of
music things what i'll do same with dvds
movies
and music is if i really really like
something i'll probably go and get a
physical copy of it whether it's a dvd
or vinyl or a cd
because
i feel like when the zombie apocalypse
hits from your movie
if if you can't go online but you have
electricity
then you plug in your dvd player in your
tv
and you can watch yeah the wizard of oz
you don't need to stream it you know
what i mean i don't actually like the
wizard of oz that much do you not no
even when it goes colour
not really i'm not
it's all right but you know how people
are like it's one of the greatest movies
ever yeah
yeah it's like it needs zombies then it
doesn't need zombies for sure lovely
question asher and i think we're moving
on it's a complicated question and we
could have done another on that
hang on here's joe he's gonna bust our
chops oh gosh you've got a
oh this is just a comment do you want to
read this bill yeah right it's from joe
in wisconsin
do you know where wisconsin is i think
on my hand ah so
new york is your middle finger over here
california i'm gonna say
just
i'm gonna say close to the middle of
your hand just about here yeah i've got
absolutely no idea though okay thanks
joe wisconsin says
not to bust your chops how dare you but
early in the sunset yellow episode you
mentioned the american
propensity yes for committing
to something with no intention or
following through that's true you did
say that i did yeah that's a keen
observation and entirely true thank you
jeff but unfortunately you brought up
minnesota as your example of a state you
could rely on for directness and honesty
well just to clue you in minnesota is
pretty wildly recognized as the ground
zero of saying exactly what you don't
mean to keep someone liking you
not to generalize but i think you are
generalizing here joe
but you really can't trust a minnesotan
to really mean
what you'd think they'd mean
for further information look up the term
minnesota nice you're doing great work
by the way thank you for the podcast joe
from wisconsin and wisconsin will tell
you exactly what they think yeah thank
you joe that's uh a shrewd comment there
if anyone from minnesota would like to
get back to us uh with a comeback on
that please write to us at the
friendship onion at castmedia.com with a
kicking cape now i love it when people
say things like that not to generalize
it then they generalize you know it's
like when people say
no offense but and you're like well i'll
decide if i get you smell yeah yeah no
offense but you're kind of an idiot
you're like well i'm gonna decide if i'm
afraid
there's a great one in england that my
dad hello austin if you're like hey
austin my dad does this all the time
right drives me mental he goes i'm not
being funny but
and that basically means i'm gonna say
something slightly offensive but i'm
hoping that i'll get away with it by
saying i'm not being funny but so my dad
will be like i'm not being funny but
you look stupid in those clothes does he
ever say like i'm not being funny but i
will never have a ton of combination
milk
condensed milk with billy boyd no notch
in a football
he's bought i showed you the picture
he's bought two tins of condensed milk
which i'm assuming because i know my dad
well he'll probably travel around with
on the off chance that you might make it
to a small spanish city that he's in
he's excited i'm excited about it yeah
and you know i don't because i know your
dad
and he's a quiet man he's a lovely man
yeah and i don't feel as if i need any
small talkers no no no i just need two
teaspoons
at least one tin yeah two he's treated
you to a tin h and we'll just sit and
watch a football or whatever football on
maybe a half something like that and
i'll just enjoy a ton of he would
condensed milk he would absolutely love
it i've spoken to him about it he's just
so you know he's prepped he's already
got the condensed milk i'll get the
spoons then brilliant
all right cool uh now there's an
explanation here of minnesota now should
we just get like color that uh they're
going don why don't we it is so too nice
is a cultural stereotype applied to the
behavior of people from minnesota
implying residents are usually courteous
reserved mild-mannered and passive
aggressive
the phrase also implies polite
friendliness an aversion to open
confrontation a tendency towards
understatement a disinclination to make
a direct fuss or stand out apparent
emotional restraint and self-deprecation
so it's basically a part of the united
states where they don't want to cause a
fuss they just want things to be fine
but i'm interested in that passive
aggressive thing
because
people like that really interest me you
know i i find it quite an art form i
know a couple of people like that who
will say things like
oh your hair is so much better like that
so they're basically saying they hated
your hair yeah it's a backhanded
compliment
i like you when you're a bit fatter yeah
yeah
that cat
it's a it's amazing oh you you suit that
weight now
yeah stuff like that yeah i love that
did you feel better what about that one
do you feel better you feel better or um
last time i saw you you looked really
tired yeah oh they're tired things
slightly irritating oh
but in in manchester yeah kind of a
colloqui i can't say this word very
easily colloquialism
is that right hello i can't say it let's
yeah go for that uh
a filler comment right is you're right
which if you if you extend that is are
you all right
but we say you're right yeah which is
basically like in scotland you know
how's it going
but if someone wants to kind of
labor the point a little bit they're
like
you're you're all right like
uh how are you coping i'm well i'm not
coping with anything fine and you get
quite a lot of passive aggressive people
in manchester being like i'll give you
that you're right
yeah you know all considering you know
with your face looking like that yeah
like that are you you're right with it
we've got a riddle someone sent us in a
rhythm oh i love reynolds i love riddles
give us that
this riddle comes from lauren b in
nashua nh where's nh new hampshire new
hampshire oh my god i nailed it i kind
of know where new hampshire is as well
do you on my hand i'm gonna guess the uh
new york california the wedding finger
middleweight through the middle wedding
finger around here yeah ah not bad dumb
i would go up a bit i'd go to the top
finger up here and that's where later on
that's where everybody looks when
they're having they're having their
votes when they're getting a new
president they always look at new
hampshire you're my political go-to
here we go right what disappears when
you say its name
now just you use your mind to think
about this because i got it remember
last time i got are you dead you worked
out what did you
when you say its name because it's
something about well
you're
you then have the knowledge so the
ignorance has disappeared but that's not
well i think you're on the right line
though so what disappears when you say
it's name name
it's name
a ghost doesn't disappear
something like a shadow john do you know
the answer and you're keeping it from us
are we in the right ballpark
yeah you're like outside the ballpark
you don't you don't have the knowledge
so you have ignorance and ignorance
disappears like a concept
that's a little bit further outside the
ballpark okay could you give us a clue
is it an actual thing that you could
pick up and grab hold of or is it an
idea is that unknown no it's not a noun
so it says no that doesn't help because
i don't know the difference between a
noun a verb an adverb an adjective i
don't know a noun you can touch a chair
a table
what's a pronoun what is that a pronoun
is a positive name
he she
yeah you're pronouncing that
you just have to know
adjective adverb i don't
mad libs i was terrible it's not
something that you can
hold on to what what disappears
when you say its name
i think it is something like ignorance
or like yeah but he's seen that outside
the ballpark it's not fair a little
outside the ballpark you didn't suggest
give us a clue jon
give us a clue something vague
oh he's thinking he's really thinking
uh
actually everybody good clue give me a
second oh hold on he's got a good clue
if we could just hold on you can think
about it for a second
uh okay hang on let me give you a very
kind general clue
okay simon and garfunkel
silence
what disappears when you say its name
because there is no silence because
you've said the word
what disappears so it's silent bills
silence and you go silence now you've
created a sound there is no silence
you've created a sound it's filled the
void but what if there was like workmen
outside
while you were trying to think of that
name
and like they were digging up the street
bring it back hold up a second
watch his legs watch his legs bring me
the pneumatic drill i don't have it high
up on the crane come down here johnny's
busting his ankle you gotta get on the
drill shut your face so there's that
type of noise going on so there's no
silence
hello
old
listeners
i've come to talk to you again
i think she was she was kind of writing
in as uh imagining uh michael allegri in
space
i love that there you go it's a good
riddle laura you can use that appreciate
what you're saying
bills we've run out of time ladies and
gentlemen if you want to use that riddle
with your friends there is no copyright
you can go ahead go ahead and use it
listen if you guys want to get in touch
with us you want to send us a food item
that you want us to try out on billion
dollar meat the world it would be great
if we could actually get hold of it in
los angeles california here send us an
email friendship onion castmedia.com
that's cass with a k or you can send us
a voicemail
to
pipe speakpipe.com com forward slash the
friendship onion leave your comments on
our youtube channel and if you rate
review and subscribers i think you've
seen billy and i put up some of your
uh reviews on our social media thank you
for that we will see you
next week bye bye toodles
[Music]